[Music]
he told me like six weeks ago and this
isn't the first time that he's leaving
from his side what it feels like is a
respect issue that if if i had enough
respect i would just be quiet
so
what i would tell you is you are married
to a very bold immature child
[Music]
this is the dr john dolone show so glad
that you're with us
so glad that you're with us if you want
to be on the show talk about mental
health parenting marriage
what's going on in your kids schools
trying to figure out what in the world
do we do next give me a buzz one eight
four four six nine three three two nine
one it's one eight four four six nine
three thirty two ninety one or go to
johndaloni.com
ask the show's about you
it's for you and it's me just walking
alongside folks trying to figure it out
um before we before we got on the air
um
the microphones were turned up really
loud and i was loud on top of the
microphones being really loud
and i blew out a couple of kelly's
eardrums she only has two actually
and
i told her
uh there's like this double pane
soundproof glass that separates us
she's one of the only people that when
she's mad at me i can feel it
i can feel it through the glass like a
laser
it's my spiritual gift
it kind of is you're like fire starter
except in people's hearts
that's awesome let's go to maven and
listen
can feel it burning right now
i can feel it burning all right let's go
to maven in tampa florida hey maven
what's up
hello how's it going great how are you
i'm pretty good excellent what's up
um
i'm having some
issues in my personal life and i decided
to ask for help i am proud of you and
thanks for thanks for giving me a shout
what's up how can i help
so
i have been diagnosed with um bipolar
disorder type 2 okay adhd ptsd and
borderline personality disorder
all by the same psychiatrist
um
no so my psychiatrist and my therapist
are working as a team to help me out so
it's
it's my team
okay so the team has just given you
all four of these diagnostics
um technically it was a team effort
between me and them because i wanted to
um figure out
what i have that's affecting me so i
could find coping mechanisms
and like
ways to
implement things in my life so i could
do things like a normal person
okay
um i'm smiling because
i'm not a normal person and i never i
never want to be one but i do understand
what you're coming from um so take take
the diagnostics let's put them over to
the side for a second what are some
things that are going on in your life
that you want to change that you want to
be different or that would make makes
you feel unnormal
um
i can't work a nine to five
um not right now how come it's been like
two and a half years
it it really
hurts my mental health it makes me
suicidal
it makes me feel like
depressed
and like i i can't do it
because what about so
um
i want to be careful with this can we
can we experiment for a second is that
cool
yeah sure okay
um
there are legitimate i cannot okay like
i cannot i cannot and i get that what i
like to do when i'm struggling with a
cannot
is i like to shift that language too
my body is choosing to
and the reason i love that is because
can't feels final to me like i can't
climb up a like a wall like spider-man
that's a thing like it's a limitation i
can't do
and so i always know that when i come up
to a wall i got to find a way around it
or find a door
but when it comes to i can't work i
always want to shift that to i could
right now my body's choosing
not to
because that allows me to say why is my
body making that choice what is it about
not working that is keeping me safe
keeping things quiet what is it that
work
does to my body or being around other
people or that pressure what is it that
my body's saying i gotta opt out of
you see the difference there one of
those is really empowering it's an
adventure let's go find it and the other
is
i'm incapable i can never
um
it's just gonna hurt like this forever
you see what i'm saying yeah so let's
shift the language again this is a pure
experiment um i don't know enough about
your situation and i would never be able
to know you as well as your psychiatrist
and your psychologist do but i want to
shift it to let's change it to
empowering language so for the last two
and a half years your body's chosen to
not work how come what is it about work
that makes you suicidal makes you
exhausted makes you what is it about
about work
[Music]
i think it's the rigidity
if that's the right word the boundary um
it's like
you have to be in this place
for eight hours
and you are not allowed to leave you're
not allowed to walk out of this this
premises
and you have to stay here
and work and do what we tell you to do
for eight hours
so it it almost feels like a heavy one
of those anxiety blankets it's weighing
it's suffocating
it is very suffocating does it work to
shift and say
for eight hours i get to be here and
for an exchange for my eight hours of
being here and doing like putting candy
on the shelves or solving this this
algorithm on the computer
you give me money
i think it would work if it was
something i liked okay i tried to use
that okay um mental
like just reframing
yeah yeah
but it didn't work for a long time like
i worked in a krispy kreme for a few
months um ago that's literally literally
an assembly line right right
it was awful yeah okay so let me ask you
this
who in your life
where and given your list of diagnostics
it may be multiple places or it may have
been very very severe
somebody
or some group of people
held you under water
you have been trapped before whether
it's an abusive relationship or a unsafe
place like you have been in it before
so much so that your body has put a pin
in that feeling in anybody anywhere that
tries to quote unquote trap me
even if it's something as benign as
hey this is the shift for work
we'll set that alarm off so loud that
you have to plug both ears and go like
we've you know i've been in a building
where the fire alarm goes off i got to
plug my ears cause i can't i can't do my
brain's gonna explode right
when did that happen to you
um i had a really bad experience in the
military and it supposed to subsequently
um led to an abusive relationship
so you you're a veteran
yes are you a combat veteran
uh no okay
um what'd you do in the military
um i was a 35 fox as an intelligence
analyst yeah
so you know better than
any non-veteran would know about
rigidity and rules and boundaries and
regulations right
yeah what about before that before the
military
i was
normal like i had signs of adhd but
yeah it was more normal
a lot of my diagnosis come from
can we can pinpoint it to things that
happen to me in the military okay okay
so
what i like to do in these moments and i
know we're not even to your question yet
is
the diagnostics are fine they help name
the dragon right yeah what i always want
to know is what is my brain trying to
protect me from
um there's even a famous psychiatrist
that went as far to say
disassociated like our
my brain is imagining other voices my
brushing brain is imagining dragons as a
way to keep us safe it's had to create
an alt reality because our current
reality is not safe it's abusive it's
scary whatever the thing may be
um i always want to know
what is
happening like what is my body trying to
protect me from because not always but
the body's such a brilliant mechanism by
which to take care of us right until it
gets off the rails and the things it's
doing to take care of us end up making
us
sicker or hurting our relationships or
whatever so anyway yeah um thank you for
sharing that with me um
that's a heart you've gone through a lot
yes
and
beyond going through a lot
now your body is so highly attuned to
other threats that may come that it's
assigning threats to things that really
aren't threats
and yeah have you reached that level
where you are anxious about being
anxious
yeah and that's that's that's hell on
earth right that's suffering with with
with no redemptive value right yeah um
it's just sitting in a in a spinning
like you're sitting in inside of a top
right it won't quit
um so what is your like tell me your
question question
so um
one of my favorite things to do is
look online for other people
who
um
suffer from the same things i do and see
like what hacks they have for life or
like what things they do to keep them on
track to
like keep their house clean or
work or like you know do something
throughout the day and there's not a lot
of like
help with the combo of bipolar and adhd
so i'll try something that works for
someone with just adhd and just bipolar
and sometimes it works because sometimes
i'm just feeling those symptoms
but for the days that i'm feeling both
symptoms
the things don't work anymore
describe your
um bp2
symptoms the hypomania like what
describe that
um so when i'm just feeling bipolar i
have hypomania for like three
days two or three days okay
and um i get bouts of energy i'm on top
of the world i'm like the greatest and i
can do anything
and then the depression comes for my
depression lasts
for
like
two or three weeks okay when i'm not
like when i'm medicated okay when you
are medicated
yeah when i'm unmedicated um it lasted
for two years can pull you down in the
abyss okay all right and so how does a
how does adhd factor into that
um
when i
feel just adhd a i have hyperactivity
i speak a lot i forget my things i like
i will start doing something and then it
will remind me of something else that i
have to be doing so quit doing that
thing and then move on to another thing
and then move on to another thing
i have no idea what you're talking about
i don't know anybody else
i don't know anybody like that if you
listen to the show for more than eight
seconds you realize oh that's that guy
um yeah okay i'm gonna tell you
the
my my initial thoughts here and
um
i wanna couch all of this that don't do
anything without talking to your
psychiatrist and you're in your
psychologist okay
let me give you the map forward for some
of these things um
for me okay
okay um
bipolar 2 is
highly highly over diagnosed as a
somebody who falls off a cliff when it
comes to depression which is very very
real it's just that black
it's just like syrup right you're just
caught in it you can't breathe and move
um
but it also can be very very real and so
i'm not gonna i don't want to be one of
those guys that's like throwing a
grenade on either side of that
conversation what i'll tell you is if
you truly have bipolar you got to take
your medication right so that's that's
square number one okay
square number two when it comes to
dealing with adhd
when i heard when you described these
things you described them as ways that
you feel things
and when it comes to borderline it's
this overwhelm my feelings are so
amplified and so powerful they're a
forest fire
and so when somebody says um
when somebody says hey man i didn't like
this paper like this i didn't like this
article you wrote to looney
like me i'll be like ah man i really
like that i thought i worked hard on it
to someone who has true borderline
personality disorder it is a
you know what i hated this so much i
wish you weren't even alive right the
feelings are so overwhelming that's what
happened okay i think that's what
happened it's and and almost you even
know this is a disproportionate response
that person's not trying to be mean but
your body is just
right it's overwhelming yeah
and then you throw the chaos of adhd on
top of that so so here is an important
thing that i've done
okay
and
what borderline people have to do
ultimately is make peace with their
feelings and act in non-accordance with
their feelings over a period of time to
where their body will recalibrate their
their feelings
and it's unmourning and it's very hard
okay
when it comes to adhd what i've had to
do for myself is stop
i have very segmented times when i
sit in feelings
but i cannot allow my feelings to
dictate what i'm doing in a given day
otherwise i will become like a kite in
the wind
and so here's an example i don't care
how i'm feeling i will exercise every
day
now i might feel like today once in a
blue moon once a month once every two
months i'm not gonna do the crazy hard
weight workout because i'm just too sore
i'm just too exhausted i was up till 2
a.m and now it's five in the morning and
it just would be dumb but i'm gonna go
for a long walk or i'm gonna ride the
exercise bike in my garage
so the debate over whether i'm doing
something is over
regardless of how i feel i'm going to do
these things
regardless of how i feel
i don't want to it's going to hurt i'm
going to get anxious i do not care those
feelings don't get a vote i will put my
clothes out for the next day before i go
to bed
i will brush my teeth and i will take a
shower every single day
whether i feel like it or not you see
what i'm saying so i'm going to take a
group of core activities that i know
help me be well
and
i'm gonna take feelings out of the
equation
i don't feel like going to bed you will
go to bed because if you don't sleep
everything downstream is chaos
i will and in my case i will go to work
even if it's angsty even if it's heavy i
might go for half a day i might go for
two hours because here's the trap that
that especially with depression here's
the trap
the trap is
i increasingly want to do less so that
the hurt will stop
and then your body learns i can make all
the hurts stop by doing nothing
which then makes it hard to breathe see
what i'm saying
and the the damning part of it is the
only way out of it is through it
that's the only way out
and so instead of saying hey work is
eight hours of prison and torture
entrapment
i'm gonna get a job where i work two
hours a day i'm gonna baby step my way
into it
even on the days i don't feel like going
i'm gonna go and when i feel like the
walls are closing in i'm gonna breathe
deeply
and when i feel suicidal i'm gonna call
my psychiatrist and say come talk to you
but i'm going to take that i'm going to
take the alternative off the table do
you see what i'm saying and what you're
going to find is
you're really much much stronger than
you thought
does that make sense yeah
because it gives me a little hope you
were oh you should have
the the core strength that you have
underneath those bricks that you're
carrying in your backpack
you can squat way more than me you are
so much strong stronger than i am
so much
it's a matter of saying can i turn this
strength can i stop carrying the stuff
around and start applying the streak
strength moving forward and then instead
of just trying to survive
see what i'm saying
yeah
um
i have really really high hopes for you
i think you can do some pretty amazing
things and because you're one of the few
people that has repelled into the depths
of hell your story and your ability to
help and serve and love other people
will be
amplified in a way that most people can
understand
thanks
do you believe me
i think so
okay i don't lie on the show
okay
i even got a ticket this morning on the
way to work and the guy said did you
know you were speeding and i was like
yep cause i was
right i'll tell you the truth
it's just been so hard for so long i
know i
know and
there's a moment where you make peace
with the fact that your body loves you
so much is trying to take care of you
it's a pretty amazing thing right
yeah
and then the other side of it is okay
the magic question is what am i going to
do now
one of the my biggest beefs with the the
mental health
ecosystem as it exists right now
um most of my colleagues are complaining
about meds whoever i don't complain
about that stuff in fact many times some
of the meds are magic they're incredible
um what i don't like about it is they've
told us that mental health is getting
the right thoughts in the right order
and then we'll if we can just think the
right way in the right direction then
we're going to be okay
and i'm convinced to be on a shadow of a
doubt
that yes the thinking is really
important but the action the doing is
equal if not more important
okay so i can get my thoughts in the
right order all day long
i don't care how i feel i'm going to get
up and make my wife's coffee
i don't care if i can't get out of bed i
will get up and make the coffee then
i'll go back to bed but i'm going to do
that one act of service today
you see what i'm saying
yeah so what's one or two things that
you could you would commit to
just for 30 days
i will do these i don't care how i feel
i don't care how
i'm gonna do these two things
um
well i had a manic episode the other day
and i decided on a morning and night
routine
good for you yes
hey listen there are few people in the
world who i love hanging out with more
than somebody in a manic state
um like they're the funnest and there's
so much and they're hilarious and
they're a lot and man you can make some
plans
right you make some polls yeah
i really rearranged my entire house too
so excellent so you rearranged the house
you made a morning routine in the
nighttime routine
did you throw all the food away because
we're going full keto we're gonna do all
the
pretty much yeah great i love it i love
it i love it
so when you're in a manic state
and then you know what's coming on the
back end especially as the manic state
starts to lose steam and it gets scary
and you want to prop it up and prop it
up how do you prop it up and keep trying
to keep going
um i actually just let myself
feel
to the crash
um okay
why i know it's coming anyway hold on
hold on hold on hold on why do you think
you're worth that crash
i don't understand the question
you think you deserve that crash
like you've thrown your hands up like
this coming this is what i get
how come i don't really know
i guess i just kind of expect it now
because the manic episodes have been so
far and few in between it's like
well this is where we were anyway so
so here's here's what what i want to
leave you with okay
my friend justin mcroberts wrote a book
um
based around his disdain for the words
it is what it is
and it's become a common refrain in our
culture that's just the way this is this
is all i'll ever be i'm always going to
be the worst thing that ever happened to
me i'm always going to be these
diagnosis i'm always going to be this
dysfunctional in this relationship
etcetera it is what it is
and his rebuke to that was no it's not
it is what you make it
right
and it's getting that little glimmer of
hope and that little glimmer of
wait a minute i'm
way i've been rucking here you remember
back in basic like i've been wrecking
here with these
cinderblocks in this backpack
i need to get these blocks out of the
bag i'm going to quit carrying them i'm
going to stop
and you're going to realize how far you
can walk and how fast you can go
so your homework assignment is this
number one continue to meet with your
psychiatric psychologist okay i'm just a
dude on a podcast i'm not going to
substitute for your mental health care
but i want you to find two or three
things
manic episode low episode
adhd is running and gunning or you're
just exhausted your body is ramping
itself up and blowing all the gas out
and then it's collapsing and then it's
slowly building the gas back up and it
blows it all out again
when borderline's kicking and you are
feeling everything
i want you to come up with two or three
things that you know keep you well that
you know feel good
that you know are right
and i will do these things these small
things every day for 30 days i will take
a five minute walk
i will write one note a day to somebody
and tell them that i love them
i will
call i'm gonna get a job i'm gonna work
two hours a day
i'm just gonna work the lunch rush and
then i'm gonna go home that's it i'm
gonna go home
i'm gonna begin practicing this new way
for my body so you can learn
hey this is the way we don't have to
keep you safe anymore this way we did
because you were in hell and we're out
now now we're surrounded by people who
love us we're surrounded by we got the
right meds we're on the right track now
we're going to begin practicing a new
way
and what you're going to find is you are
way way stronger than you could have
ever imagined
and as i end all these calls maven
if you're ever considering hurting
yourself
you've got to make that call and i trust
that since you've said this in the past
that you you have made that call and i'm
proud of you
every time moving forward you will make
this call
i'm convinced like i said earlier
there's light at the end of this tunnel
[Music]
pick a couple of things and keep
practicing keep stepping keep stepping
keep stepping get those bricks out of
your backpack we'll be right back
hey good folks dr john dolone here all
right we have to talk about sleep when
life gets busy it's the first thing we
neglect we stay up later we binge
another series and we think we can do
everything i know because i've been
guilty of it but you and me and all of
us we have to change we need sleep sleep
is at the core of every mental physical
and relational thing we do and i found a
good night's sleep starts with a great
mattress and that's why i love dream
cloud mattresses and right now dream
cloud is running their biggest offer
ever just for our listeners you can get
599 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 cash discount that's a
total of
849 dollars in accessories and savings
that's pillows a mattress protector and
luxury sheets it's time to prioritize
getting the rest your body and your mind
need because your mental health matters
so go to dreamcloudsleep.com
daloni or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress today
and enjoy
849 in savings and accessories
all right we're back let's go to chris
down the road in memphis tennessee
what's up chris
hey what's up just rocking on dude what
are you doing
i am just
on him
what's up
so i'm having a problem with
communication with my wife
and not in the way of being able to
express our needs with each other and
being able to fulfill them
but in the way of just having a friendly
conversation be able to hold the
conversation and just having something
to talk about like if i had a friend
come into my car
and we're driving 30 minutes down the
road like we'll talk all the way until
we get to destination b but
i feel like a lot of times with my wife
i don't know if there's just nothing to
talk about or i have just so much stuff
running through my brain
that work or
it's just it's starting to cause a
problem with connection
why why have you put that expectation
that you have to talk everywhere you go
no it's not i'm not saying that
at all the time we need to talk but it
has become a problem to where
there's just not enough talking like
we're just sitting too much or i'm not
communicating with her enough just being
a friend to her hmm
why are you choosing that
i don't know i don't know if it's
if it's just my mind is consumed with
work or
yeah like i feel like there's nothing to
talk about or i don't know
no it's not one of those two things
because both of those are choices
so i'm not looking for the question
beneath that question because everybody
i know works really hard
and they could if they wanted to let
their minds be consumed at work all the
time and there's a few days
out of a month that my brain is super
consumed with work
um and that's just part of being a human
and being alive
but there are days when i can choose i'm
just gonna keep thinking about working
through my work or i'm gonna
choose to think about and talk about my
wife talk to her about our home about
our family life and stuff like that
um
my wife and i here's what i'm struggling
my wife and i dude have
like she likes singer songwriters man
and i do too but i really like old punk
rock and i like to go to metal shows and
she would prefer to go to a theater
and
she writes like
historical fiction man and i
you know
i can't think of two people who i know
who have more different things that they
care about and love in the world
than me and my wife
and there's never something there's we
always have things to talk about and i'm
not afraid of two hours of silence when
we're driving on a trip somewhere that's
some great time too just to sit in my
head so
i don't put i don't put this weight on
the other side of the scale and that's
what what i'm getting at is
either a there are things you want to
talk about that you're afraid to bring
up with her or that you can't bring up
with her because it's not safe to
there's something you want to tell her
and you don't want to do it or b you're
just kind of a jerk and you're just
staying in your own head you're kind of
you're starving your wife of your
relationship
am i missing something
you know i would say
a lot of times like
might not bring up stuff because
like if it has to do with work or
whatever i mean we own a couple
companies and
sometimes i don't want to bring up
certain situations with her because
she might want to do something a
different way
um
and i i disagree with it and it's it's
just kind of getting past the argument
or
um
sometimes just best to
not tell her about it um
so let me let me let me let me give you
a line i want you to tattoo this on your
heart okay
conflict delayed is conflict amplified
a hundred percent of the time
you've now started like lying to your
wife by omission
because it's just easier
instead of having a harder conversation
which which is should we be in business
together or is it wise for us to run
businesses together and be married
because it looks like we're on a
collision course here
well it's not that it's not that she
runs it with me it's just
she doesn't run it at all um it's just
if i were to come and bring a situation
to her and i tell her how i handled it
then she would give her
input that
a lot of times it's not a
constructive criticism it's more of just
a criticism sure that's fair so are you
more than work
a lot of times i'm not but i try to be i
mean i definitely try to be
so
give me like a a solid question
here's what it feels like it feels like
you are
um
again dude lean in and tell me i'm wrong
okay tell me i'm wrong on this it feels
like you were in a pool
and the water's like up to your waist
and you are just splashing around and
you're like ah i can't get out of the
water it's wet in here
and then we're all sitting on the side
like we'll just get out of the pool
you're like i can't
like i'll just get a pool man like
i i can't i don't i don't know where
i don't know what you're struggling with
there's something beneath this that
you're that you're not telling me what
is it
i guess
i would say
[Music]
um
how do i how do i bring my wife into my
work life
without
even though it's not her
ambition or her wants or her needs to be
a part of it really in the way that i
want her to be
um there it is there it is right there
yeah
she doesn't care about your job she
cares about her you
should give a crap about your business
intricacies and who did what and the
plumbing at this facility's busted and i
can't believe in the profits over she
didn't care any of that she cares about
chris
right and because this means so much to
you like you're like a favorite band
when you were in high school
you've said
here's a rule i made dude if you didn't
like seinfeld i knew we weren't going to
be friends i used to ask that question
like in the first time i the first
conversation i met people hey do you
like seinfeld and they'd be like nah and
i just know we're not gonna be friends i
have one friend in my life who doesn't
like seinfeld to this day and that's my
wife
of 20 years
but you've created a world where if you
don't like this then we're probably not
gonna that's like why have you boxed
yourself in that way she didn't care
about your job so what
like what do you want well i just i just
feel that
i wish
i thought going into marriage i thought
we would be able to
um go forward together and build
something together and even if she's on
the sideline of not running it but at
least be like
i guess more of a cheerleader or more of
a
i don't know i guess have interest
okay can i poke it what i think it is
absolutely how long have you been
married
coming up on three years okay all right
perfect so first thing you mentioned is
beautiful and this is your starting
point with your wife
you had a picture of what marriage was
going to be and that was going to be you
were going to be busting it real hard
crush like you were going to be working
really hard in business you're going to
do good
and she was going to be super she's
going to be right there by your side
cheering you on
and now you're three years in and you're
realizing i'm busting it really hard and
my wife could care less what my job is
and i try to bring her in and then it
ends up she gives me some bad advice
like why i just fire him he's like i
can't just fight and now we're in a
thing right
yeah it took me 16 years 15 years
trying to think when our last big
mess was me and my wife
let me say 15 years
for me to tell my wife
i've been working for 15 years for
you to say
um
three or four but
four magic words
i'm proud of you
and as a texas male it was really hard
for me to say those words out loud i
felt ashamed i felt small i felt
embarrassed i just wanted my wife to say
i'm really proud of you i see how hard
you're working for the family i see how
hard you're working the lives of other
people etc etc
and until i said those words out loud
she didn't get it because she thought
our fights were when i was coaching like
i would just tell her all the track
times she's like i don't care and when i
was working in higher ed i was telling
her about all the budget numbers and the
suicides and that i just don't i mean i
don't care about that i don't like it i
don't i mean it's not a thing if i
wanted to do if i was interested in that
i would have done those jobs too and i
don't i don't care about them
and i took that to me and she didn't
care about me
when i came to find out is she loved me
deeply
i just wanted her to be proud of me
and when i said that she broke down i
broke down and she said man i sure would
have shoe told me that 15 years ago
because i'm so proud of you i can't
breathe right so it was giving her
language that i needed it was me um
doing the brave courageous probably the
most mainly thing i could do which just
say here's what i need
that makes sense
right and i don't know that you need
somebody that is walking alongside you
just pat you on the back and saying tell
you how great and smart and beautiful
you are and how
care about your business as much as you
want her to acknowledge how hard you
work in and the contribution you're
making to your home is that fair
so i'd start there with a conversation
and dude the the pictures you had coming
into marriage everyone it throws
everyone off so you're not in a bad spot
i just had to quit talking to my wife
about uh
track times i had to quit talking about
higher ed issues and talked to her about
other things way to develop other things
to talk about
we had to create shared experiences so
we would have things to talk about
and sometimes she would just like
take one for the team and listen to me
talk about work and vice versa i didn't
really understand we were talking about
with k-12 education whatever but i
listened i got there see what i'm saying
it's both in it's gonna take
is is there a deeper tension here
i would say that
um
it's hard to if she if she doesn't want
to be involved and she doesn't you know
like you said that she didn't care about
the business she cares about me
it's hard to want to grow or i want to
grow and continue working and to
continue building
but if she
doesn't want me to it's hard on me to
like
give up my dreams or wants
if it's not ours
um
and i i it's almost as if i'm trying to
force it to be ours yeah
and
i think that's like devastating to me
because it's all i've really ever wanted
in my entire life was what was what was
what
just
building a business and growing a
business and
so she told you i don't want you growing
a business
growing it more than what we have it's
um
normally that conversation is i miss my
husband
like yeah right that's exactly what it
is and i think i've told this on the
podcast if i haven't shame on me
it was this year that my wife held my
face and said john we have enough stop
i need you and i'm thinking yeah but i
need more this i need to write another
book and i got to get this thing out i
got to get i'm going on a tour i've got
to go hit the road
and she said we have enough
and i had to drop my shoulders and ask
myself am i chasing ambition am i
chasing ego or am i trying to give my
family a better shot
yeah and that was me looking in the
mirror had nothing to do with my wife
in fact she was the one that just called
it out said from this point forward any
more hours you work any more money you
make isn't for us it's to feed your own
whatever you're trying to solve
and that was a hard thing for me to hear
but she was right
and by the way it's not mutually
exclusive
what i've done now is i've haven't
really throttled back that much but i
have had to speak my needs
and be more firm at work and set up
boundaries at work and i've been much
more clear at home
little things like putting my phone down
leaving my social media phone here at
work doing some things that just create
some space at home so that when i'm
there i'm fully there and i'm not
thinking about the business all day as a
young business owner
building a business
can take your life over and it can take
your soul over and i've done the
research and sat with folks who have
done that for 50 years and they're 60
and they're think and they think
oh i gave
up everything i have no memories i've
got no kids or i've got two kids that
don't like me i've got a big bank
account and i've got nothing
and so the work is not
giving up one or the other don't back
yourself into a corner that way but it's
saying what does growing the business
look like and what does
really swan diving um into the
relationship with my wife look like
those aren't mutually exclusive they're
going to come they're going to they're
going to be a teeter totter it's going
to be a balance and she's dealing with
with that picture from the other side
too right she had a picture of a
marriage where at five o'clock every day
chris would come home and we would talk
and laugh and
and her picture's gonna be different too
that's why where you start is y'all go
on a retreat together you've heard me
say this a million times
go on a retreat together and say hey
we're three years in
we have different pictures
let's create a unified single picture
and let's work towards it together and
that's going to be you giving up some
stuff and her giving up some stuff and
both of you getting some great things
together and then we're off to the races
do you see what a different view that is
yeah
can you do you think you can do that or
you think your wife is saying i want you
to quit this business and go do
something else
no she doesn't want me to quit or
anything but it's just
she wants the growth to stop but
what is the growth costing her
um
it costs her
the
i guess mental stress on me when i come
home
okay um you hear what that means you are
not telling you're not hearing her words
correctly
her words are not telling you to stop
working on the business even though
that's what she said
her words are i'm watching the man i
love die in front of me and call it his
dream
i'm watching the man i love the man i
stood before our friends and family and
said i'm all in forever i'm watching him
slowly drown in front of me and say look
how happy i am
that's what she's saying chris
so how do i get past my
my
desires my
it's not both and
grow the business and decide that next
year you're going to make 30 000 fewer
dollars and you're going to hire an
assistant that's going to take care of x
and y and z
decide next year you're going to make 65
000 less dollars and hire a senior
manager that's going to run the ship for
you
[Music]
put on all an on-call staff so that at
five o'clock only three people call you
and that's if something is on fire
somebody's dead
everything else can work till tomorrow
this is about um a
young business owner running a new
business trying to grow it and having no
boundaries
and what you're going to find is two
important cool things number one
this thing will keep going without you
hovering and breathing over it every
second and number two when you have time
to think and time to have great wild
evenings with your wife and y'all go do
fun stuff and like each other and have
fun and you
develop that relationship you're gonna
be a thousand times better back on the
ball field
and i know that it sounds like yo dude
whatever i'm i live it dude i'm doing it
right now i promise you
i think it starts with this i think it
starts with you taking your wife out and
saying over the last three years i have
been cheating on you with my business
and
i have told you you're my priority but
my behavior is a language and what i've
demonstrated to you is the most
important thing in my life is building
this business
and i've got my pro priorities backwards
my most important priority in my life is
my wife
it's our family it's what we're doing
together
and i'm really passionate about this
business
and i'll give it all up if that's what
it takes but i don't think that's what
it takes
can you see some things in me that
you've seen shift and change over the
last few years
that i can
work to manage around as this business
grows
things like time things like a personal
assistant things like somebody checking
email things like a commitment to it six
o'clock when you get home the phones are
all off and i'm gonna outsource that
whatever those things are on the
weekends i do not take work calls unless
there is somebody dead
or dying
right i'm going to create some really
strong boundaries
your wife's telling you that she loves
you and she misses you and she doesn't
want to watch you die right in front of
her
she's not telling you to quit your
business
she's just watching the business kill
you
and please my brother
don't don't see this as the end of times
it's not your business or your wife you
can absolutely do both together it's
going to be
coming up with boundaries and working
together
holler and let me know how that dinner
goes i'd love to hear about it we'll be
right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless homebuyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades
and their home buyer edge program will
help you skip a bunch of the stress
here's how it works apply to become a
churchill certified home buyer and cap
your interest rate for 90 days then
you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee to
help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back
check them out at churchillmortgage.com
delony and get the homebuyer edge today
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's take one more let's go
to st louis missouri and talk to christy
hey christy what's up
hey how are you dr john thank you for
taking my call i'm doing great thanks
for calling what's up
um i was calling uh because
i i'll start with the question that i
have
um
how do you know in your marriage um when
someone else has checked out and
you um you are holding it together but
they're gone
and so i'll give you the like backstory
now um
i
my husband and i have been married 20
years
and um we had a great dating
relationship um just like doing fun
stuff like totally active like hiking
and
caving and
catching uh lightning bugs and just just
all kinds of fun stuff shortly into our
marriage
we had what i didn't realize was a
communication problem
and so i'm extroverted i talk a lot
and
he's introverted and i think he really
likes the social outlet in that
he can go places with me and they take
the social pressure off and he can
engage with people
and um
not not have all that pressure and so um
we've
we've had a lot of
outside um problems with our marriage
just as far as we've had deployments um
started a business we've had court
battles we've had a sick child who was
in the hospital for
um
it was it could have been terminal and
it
lasted for years his condition which is
now better and so um
we we have been through a lot together
um we started a business eight years ago
where he did it was his baby and
um i'm all in like i
i like to do the people side of things
and
um i'm good at integrating so i've been
helping with the business and um just
over the last
well
to add a little more drama to our life
that business is going so well so why
not expand and start another so
we have another one in a different part
of the country and so
um
i would say this communication problem
is just grown and grown
and he doesn't really
um
want to hear me talk
so
um
he's he's okay by himself he's really
smart he's well read he um
he sets
back and analyzes people and
situations he's very discerning um if he
misses the mark on discernment
the
um verdict is already
filled like you know um but
um
just i mean he is my best friend so just
over the last
i don't know maybe 10 years it's just
gotten worse and worse
we have five boys and um
[Music]
they work in our business our family
works in our business our friends and so
he told me like six weeks ago and this
isn't the first time that he's leaving
and
um i feel like
i could
um talk him into counseling
because he's agreed to that and maybe
somehow kind of guilt him interesting
but i can tell he's checked out yeah
i'm
sorry thanks i hate that
saying that out loud it's hard huh
um when he told you he's leaving what
was the context there
um it's really funny
yeah it sounds hilarious christy
so
it um it was over a nice chest but i
know that that it's not over an ice
chest
um
for him i can tell you from his side
what it feels like is a respect issue
that if if i had enough respect i would
just be quiet
so um what i would tell you is you are
married to a very bold immature child
that's probably the last thing you think
and if he was sitting here i would tell
him the same thing that i love him
um but the way he's chosen to handle the
world is to take his ball and go home
and if anybody doesn't want to play with
the rules that he's set up for the game
then they i'm just going to cut them out
of my life
which you're free to do but it's what
children do
yeah adults especially adults in
committed relationships sit down and say
hey i made a judgment about a thing and
i may be wrong or my judgment may be
right
but my response to that judgment is
killing me
and it's killing the people that i love
so i'm gonna i'm gonna do some different
things i wanna do some different things
together
and my guess is whether he saw stuff
overseas or people deal with drama
differently people deal with heartache
and heartbreak and stress and trauma
differently
there's a little nine-year-old kid
inside or a little 14 year old boy
inside that's been at war for a long
long time who's
exhausted
yeah
and
it feels like he's been pulling a plow
for a long long time and i'm just gonna
quit pulling the plow
so to answer your original question how
do you know when somebody's checked out
you know when somebody's checked out
all right that's not really the question
sounds like your question is
what am i supposed to do now right
and my guess is you have been
you've heard me say this before you've
been sharing a bed with a guy where
you've been two inches apart from him
but y'all have been 5 000 miles away
from each other for a long long time
yeah and the question is do y'all want
to
put on your explorer hats and your snow
boots and
go on a great adventure to
re-connect over a long bridge that y'all
got to build on the way
um are y'all going to go your separate
ways
right
and the unfortunate part is you can claw
and climb and walk halfway through
siberia but the other person's got to
make that journey on their side
right
and guilt will get somebody so far but
there's it doesn't get them over there
right
yeah
um
i don't think it's a communication
problem i think there's probably
communication problems
but christie you haven't liked him for a
long time either
you haven't i tried to i don't really
mind myself i know but you haven't
and
both of you innately feel that the other
person doesn't like them so you create
these worlds that y'all can both inhabit
and still share a bed together
and that sews that's the that's the
first seed in the soil for we got to do
some we're going to do something else
with other people because this is going
gonna work
yeah
and you don't like him because of fill
in the blank and he doesn't like not
being liked so he ends up doing more of
fill in the blank and now we're off into
a dance that you wake up 10 years later
like i know you are
yeah
or i wanted you to grieve our kid in the
hospital like this and you just went off
and did this and i didn't think you
really cared well i didn't somebody had
to and now all of a sudden we've
started another dance
so you started the whole call so here's
the only path forward okay and i don't
say this dramatically this is this this
is your single shot okay okay i will
tell you this i have high high hopes for
your
marriage high hopes
i had a similar situation different but
similar
five years ago four years ago
where my wife and i sat down and said
we've got to make a hard choice right
now
and if we're gonna stick in it this is
what it's gonna take and both of us
double down and it's i will tell you now
on the other side of that it's like
i'm pretty arrogant i don't know a lot
of people who are in the situation i'm
in my marriage it's pretty good
okay
that's great it's pretty good
congratulations yeah exactly
yes
thanks idiot
what an ass thanks delony right
so yeah that's great i'm just trying to
give you a light at the end of the
tunnel here
okay i love it when you started this
call you started this call by telling me
how much fun y'all used to have
yes
that season is over
and the more you try to make
in the present what used to be
the more you hold up an impossible
mirror to you and your husband we don't
look like that anymore we don't look
like it's like the 40 year old woman who
doesn't look like she's 18 anymore of
course not
because she's 40 is different now
and by
not looking at the 40 year old in the
mirror and seeing how beautiful and
stunning and wild and courageous and
full of scars and adventures she is
it's just all well you're not 18 anymore
that's not 18. you see what i'm saying
that's what you're doing with your
marriage
and so the only path forward
is both of you sitting down and saying
okay and you've heard me say this a
thousand times i'll say it a million
times more
the twin towers got knocked down
and we can never sweep up all that glass
and steel and dust and rebuild the
towers with those same ingredients it's
over it's gone
we have to excavate everything and
decide today we're gonna build something
completely new
what is that going to look like
and in my house it was i need this from
you
i need this i need this i need this and
then my wife was like i need this and
this and this and i said i will go all
in on those things
and i will trust that you will go all in
on the other
but you got to build something looking
to the future not trying to reclaim
something from the past because the past
doesn't exist anymore it's a different
time in a different place in a different
planet
sure
you know what i mean
my question to you is do you like this
guy enough to do that
yes
will you
yeah definitely
if he sat down with you and said all
right here's what i need
we're 42 years old i want crazy
rambunctious sex
and i want us to once a month go on a
trip together and i want you to stop
talking about work and also can we just
watch romantic comedies because i know
he's super into those
and can we not right whatever the thing
is and you vice versa
saying
what i really need is when you get home
you're off the phone and you're just
gonna talk to me you know what my white
one of the things my wife needed we call
it chit chat
i don't even know what that is really
except
when she's in the kitchen i sit up at
the bar
and we just talk about stuff
and there's sometimes i think i don't
know what we're doing right now she's
just chopping vegetables doing some
stuff looking at stuff but we're just
talking about things
and that makes her soul quiet it gives
her peace
i don't understand it but i'm all in
and now i've grown to love chitchat time
i don't even know what we're doing right
that's great you see what i'm saying
yes we don't it doesn't have to over
complicate it it's just here's what i
need right now and then here's the cool
part and the annoying part
in three years your needs will be all
different again
and this will become a part of the
rhythm of your life is what do you need
in this season
what do you need in this season and the
adventure is not i gotta get all my
needs met the adventure is dude i'm
gonna go over the top to meet your needs
because you're going over the top to
meet mine
i'm gonna do s
i'm gonna meet all of your needs so that
you can meet mine
it sounds transactional but it's not
it's deepening this thing
but it starts with sitting it down
saying okay the towers fell over
are you in this to rebuild something new
with me
and here's where that's a scary
vulnerable conversation christy he may
say no
okay
he may say no
but he might say yes
is that fair yeah yeah it really is and
then a part of the the path going
forward is
like
new york city didn't just rebuild it
they had to go get experts right so you
may need a marriage counselor to teach
all how to
i say this my need out loud i
automatically feel angry and i don't
want to feel angry and when i feel angry
then you feel mad that i'm angry
and they'll help you with some of the
dances right it's just a therapist is a
dance coach i'm going to teach y'all how
to interact with each other and move
throughout your day a little bit
differently
but i got real high hopes if we sit down
and have that conversation
okay and he's gonna have to agree
i'm gonna act like an adult moving
forward i'm not gonna take my ball and
just go home every time
yeah what is what if the answer is vague
i mean do i read it into it or do i just
take it as a no what is that say one
more time
what if the answer is vague
do i just read into it no no no no
you're that's the communication issue
both of you are getting into each
other's heads fundamental attribution
error they call it in the nerd world i'm
going to get into your head and think
why you just did what you just did and
i'm going to judge you based on what i
just why i think you did what you just
did
okay get out of each other's heads
vague
we don't do vague anymore your
relationship doesn't have time for vague
right
right vague is a a screen in front of
your oxygen mask i don't got time for
that i need oxygen now
yeah
the question is
will you build something new with me
because if you're in it starts tomorrow
at 5 00 a.m
okay we're gonna go go for a walk and
maybe you do the hard work um and say up
front and say here's three things i need
okay and here's three things i'm willing
to do
and by the way christy as someone who
talks a lot i'm a lot
you know what i mean
so when my wife needs quiet time i
understand it because i'm a lot
i don't feel like i am but everyone's
look on their face around me assures me
that i am okay
so some of that i have to go deal with
my own counseling i gotta figure out my
own stuff because i bring a lot of my
stuff and you're gonna have to do that
too okay
okay
but
um the whole thing the whole enterprise
is a risk
i think you're worth the risk i think
he's worth the risk i think 20 years in
your fight boys are worth the risk
i think all of it is worth the risk and
the beauty on the other side of this
thing can be something unimaginable
yes i believe that
okay
there can't be any more hedging from
this point forward
okay
okay you can't go halfway you can't have
sort of a talk you can't have a vague
talk you got to go all in
okay is that cool
yeah you let me know how that goes
i sure will thank you cool oh by the way
i called him a child you're kind of one
too right is that fair
probably 100 100
so
let's have a we'll have a grown-up
conversation hey will you let me know
how the conversation goes
absolutely okay i'll be thinking about
you guys man i uh i want the best for
y'all
and
to everybody who's in a relationship
we're struggling right now
who's wondering
that next
habit
conflict delayed is conflict amplified
it'll just get
have it
sit down and say i miss you i want to
build something new we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
hey we're back oh that's a fun show so
far um hey real quick before we roll
i wanna y'all know that i can't stand
people who invent diagnostics and then
label each other with them i call it the
uh google diagnostics
uh i got sent this by someone on the
team so i wanna talk about this pop
psychology term i keep hearing on social
media coming up um
and from our team
it's called high functioning anxiety oh
my gosh
what people mean when they say high
functioning anxiety is that they are
super anxious on the inside and their
life is working really good on the
outside okay you know this person you
you might even be this person i was this
person for a long time it's the guy that
keeps getting promoted at work but has
panic attacks during the day
it's the uh mom who's on time for every
practice but it's constantly on edge
because the schedule ruins
it's anxiety that's easy to hide ignore
or diminish life because life isn't off
the rails right it's like no we're going
great we're going great we're going
great because the car is not in the
gutter that does not mean you're driving
safely or doing anything that's going to
go
down go
uh have any long-term viability here's
the annoying part there's no such thing
as high-functioning anxiety there is no
diagnosis there is
any it's this obsession with branching
everything off and giving everything a
protected label and stop
stop
our cultures turned anxiety into
something it's not and made it sound
crazy with these big scary labels
anxiety is crippling i've had it it'll
it will collapse you and it will make
life hard i've had it been there still
got it okay but i've got management
strategies now
i want you to think of anxiety as simply
your brain trying to keep you safe so if
you have something that you've googled
and determined you've got high
functioning anxiety what that means is
the life you are leading is killing you
it's your body trying to get your
attention that the yes we are making
lots of money and getting promoted and
all the moms think we're the best and
and we're gonna die
your body will eventually shut you down
right or maybe you're in loads of debt
and like look how nice my house is look
how nice my car is look how nice my
degree on my wall is and your body's
like we're not safe we're not safe we're
not safe because we owe other people
money
and they get to decide what we do today
not us
so whatever it is anxiety is the smoke
alarm it's the message that your body's
trying to give you to let you know that
you're not safe
if it sounds like you
and again it's like it sounds like me
if it sounds like you number one stop
creating diagnosis for yourself and
that's the mental health practitioners
here
creating additional diagnostics creating
additional labels that are like ad
adjunctive to existing that it's not
helping
people who are hurting need to be
grounded in reality here is reality
and creating another label on top is not
helping
okay
there's a ton more i could say about it
here i actually wrote a blog about it
wrote an article about it go to
ramseysolutions.com or go to
jandaloney.com and you can check out the
article on high functioning anxiety
and how it is a real thing but it's
actually not even a real thing all right
so to wrap up today's show
kelly's
second favorite band ever bachmann
turner overdrive we talked to a couple
of business owners today dealing with
relationships
talking about taking care of business
and it goes like this
you get up every morning from your alarm
clocks warning warning not your alarm
clock just from your alarm clocks
warning take the 815 to the city there's
a whistle up above people pushing people
shoving and the girls who try to look
pretty and if your train's on time and
you can get to work by nine and start
your slaving job to get your pay if
you've ever get annoyed look at me i'm
self-employed i love to work at nothing
all day and i'll be
taking care of business
every day
take care of business
and working overtime
work out
i don't know about that one kelly
taking care of business every day that's
what we do on this show see you later